it's time for roses and Rosie
[Music]
20:19 am i right guys the year is over
and I'm flippin exhausted so much drama
in the bachelor world it's the eve of
our new year
I gotta get excited for the new season
how am I gonna do it what could get me
going oh I know
[Music]
[Applause]
hello 2020 what you doing
2020 what's happening 2020
hey guys all right let's do this cheers
to you
cheers to The Bachelor franchise Oh doh
I crushed that absolutely my back there
was a time I couldn't have played that
better just like this couldn't have been
a better year for The Bachelor the
Bachelorette and bachelor in paradise Oh
everybody I'm saying that between cold
Underwood's season of The Bachelor
between Hannah Brown season of The
Bachelorette and between everybody
season of bachelor in paradise we
possibly had the most dramatic bachelor
year ever let's toast to it
[Music]
that's got to be a new record so quickly
but 2019 was a lot right it was a lot to
take in so I am here to recap with you
the most dramatic moments of 2019 do you
agree that this was the most dramatic
year overall in bachelor franchise
history let me know in the comments
below what are your new year's
resolutions tell me mine is to finally
start my podcast okay so number 10
multiple fights we had John Paul Jones
and Derek we had Jordan and Cruz
people were thrown off the show like
actually fighting yeah only on this show
can things go from zero to what so fast
I love it my talk to you real quick John
Paul Jones and Derrick was an unexpected
argument wasn't it that was what mean
that was so dramatic was we love John
Paul Jones we love Derrick why are they
fighting we hate it we don't like it and
sometimes drama isn't about conflict
sometimes drama is just about emotion
and tears and that's why also on our
countdown our Derek Christian and Demi
Christian and Demi getting together
they've since broken up but it was
emotional there were lots of Tears there
was lots of maturity look if this is
what makes you happy you're making the
right decision
lots of overcoming no Colton Underwood
season of The Bachelor he was a bachelor
that not everybody was crying for but
who did cry a lot on bachelor in
paradise and that put him in prime
position to be an unforgettable leading
man and one of the moments I cannot
forget number eight is Colton and Cassie
the shake down this moment was a
shakedown because not only were they
shaking down the truth out of each other
but Colton's literally shaking oh are
you alright
I mean it for a big guy shake it around
are you cold no he wasn't cold he was
sad and scared
this was me during that whole
conversation do you see where I am you
see right edge of my seat okay
oh I just pulled something yes this is
why I don't sports because I cannot I'm
not someone who can come out with an
unexpected movement I have to know what
the movements are gonna be I do a yoga
class
downward dog okay Child's Pose okay
Sports react to what's happening dad out
that's what's happening right now
I love these decorations
oh I'm on cameo you could get a New
Year's Eve message from me doing a
holiday discount shameless plug look at
all of our fun decorations this is a
disco ball for the new why is there a
hole in it this a cup no way the straw
is clean 2020 the year of try we saw
some very public photos of you and Gigi
Hadid yeah so where are you guys not
right now hmm you and Gigi we're just
we're just friends
number seven Tyler Cameron and Gigi
Hadid make our countdown yes oh when I
found out about this news whoooo I
needed a little booze because who knew
that our respectful King would meet up
with one of the queens of the runway who
knew that our model contestant would get
together with a supermodel who knew that
Tyler C would be with Gigi you know what
I'm saying that was unexpected because
never has a contestant wound up with his
supermodel yeah next up number six the
windmill reveal our drawers dropped when
we discovered who was behind the
windmill sex and we learned that it was
Peter in the windmill with Hannah brown
just like a game of Clue
so that was an edge of your seats reveal
wasn't it you're incredible guy and I'm
a single girl number five Oh Hannah
Sylar and the morning after I just
thought maybe we could go her dream can
just say it I would love to just tell me
went on that proud to be Tyler seeing a
tyler t as he walked away from hannah be
the morning after he yes these two seems
to get together for the drink they
discussed on the finale and the
paparazzi photos proved that it happened
wow-wow-wow when i woke up and saw those
in my inbox I didn't want to hurt you I
know people think that that was a
malicious act number four stagecoach
sexcapades yes Blake horseman horseman
horseman horseman I still can't say his
name sorry Blake had many a moment in
paradise I just like feel really
disrespected humor and those first few
episodes were unforgettable Blake was in
tears Blake was freaking out Blake was
losing his marbles things between him
and Kailyn came to a truly unforgettable
unstoppable eruption Kailyn came into
paradise with an agenda she was ready to
shut Blake's ish down and that
combination of Blake's apparent naivete
innocence unawareness masking of
whatever you want to call it with
Kalin's fiery ferociousness brought us a
swinging pendulum in paradise that
lasted several episodes until the whole
damn thing fell apart
we had tears we had a storm we had a
Blake down and Christina Sherman shelf
and Christina was there - Hannah season
jam-packed with moments number three the
Jag girlfriend scandal difficult to
pinpoint exactly the dramatic second of
time here
we had Jed's girlfriend revealing things
while the season was airing we had Judds
girlfriend giving interviews we had Jed
and Hanna finally talking it out on the
finale was reached out to about doing
the show I just never would have dreamed
that I would meet the person that I
wanted to spend the rest of my life with
on a reality TV show oh my god
but this scandal the scandal was a
moment sometimes things are an actual
moment like that's that moment that that
happened that was the moment and
sometimes things are low-lives
that was a moment do you know what I'm
saying
okay you do you told me you're having
sex or you had sex with one or multiple
of these guys I'd be wanting to go home
and number two Hanna and Luke's big
blowup
Luke caused trouble all season long
which made this big moment even more
unbelievable
there's something in me is refusing me
to get into that vehicle right now
because my really I can probably get you
to go in that limo Luke and Hanna
finally come head to head for the
massive blow-up that would send him
packing finally this is where Luke asked
Hanna if she'd slept with other men and
Hanna unforgettably said yes I have had
six
yeah
Jesus still loves me Cheers
to Jesus why was the moment so
incredibly dramatic Hannah and Luke were
the perfect combination of a guy who was
unaware of how what he was saying was
coming across and a woman who wasn't
afraid to tell him their personalities
meshed mashed and collided into an
absolute firestorm of dramatic
television do you say how you feel me
you know windmill probably he probably
literally Hannah put him in his place
and Luke fell flat on his face
okay we need a new couch we're getting
one
[Music]
he just jumped dance and of course no I
can hit that no right do you see are you
laughing at me yes you are because JC
can actually sing so he's behind the
camera going that sounds rough I want to
run just like Whitney the fence jump
everybody we had been building up to it
all season long and what I love about
this franchise it did not disappoint
am i right I mean we knew the fence jump
was coming we didn't know we were gonna
get Chris Harrison running gold dad
Scholten
all dad Colton and then he ran for like
30 seconds and he's like where is he I
think I heard dog over there he is gone
crazy
I don't know how hard he looked whatever
it was fabulous television unparalleled
where else are you seeing that The
Bachelor so that's the countdown
everybody
Happy New Year here's to 2020 I cannot
wait for pilot Pete season of The
Bachelor I cannot wait to talk and
interact with you guys more and bottom
line cheers to you of course we'll do a
full season of roses and Rosie starting
with the premiere and speaking of you
know as I look back on bachelor
bachelorette seasons I think about where
things will fall in the lexicon of the
great lore and history of this franchise
how will we remember I think for
Colton's season virginity and a fence
jump for Hannah's season empowerment in
a windmill for Peter season all weekend
I don't know TVD that I'm excited are
you stoked for the season let me know in
the comments below I think it's gonna be
good
thank you thank you thank you from the
bottom of my deep deep deepest part of
my soul for watching roses and Rosie I
can't wait for this year it's going to
be amazing
I wish all of you all the best as we
embark on a new decade and we will of
course be here covering Peter Webber
season of The Bachelor every Tuesday
with new episode of roses and rosy bye
[Music]
thank you all right 2020 Peter Webber
season what's your prediction an
entirely new level of windmill like
literally in the window oh my god the
best window yeah all right
four-star window sort so that 2020 here
we go my friend
[Music]
this is really dirty yeah no that's very
it's unclean and I don't know if we even
wash Tony first bought it I don't think
so no no I don't know if we bought that
we might have found it somewhere it's
trash actually really valet more careful
yeah very used
[Music]